The ocean covers over
70% of our planet.
And yet, what we know about it
barely scratches the surface.
Beneath its swell is a largely
unexplored universe,
until recently, beyond
the gaze of human eyes.
So why do we know so little
about the ocean?
For a start, immense pressure
presents huge challenges
for divers and equipment alike.
In many ways, it’s easier
to send a mission to space.
But with new technology,
such as submarine robots,
this hidden realm is starting
to reveal its secrets.
So, what’s down there?
Well, there’s water. Lots of it.
1,419,120,000 cubic kilometres,
to be about as precise
as you can be.
And in that water, there’s fish -
the main source of protein
for around three billion people.
But there’s a lot more than
just fish down there.
Extraordinary, otherworldly creatures
dwell in the depths,
with new ones
discovered all the time.
Many are gelatinous -
jellyfish that disintegrate
if you try to catch them in a net.
In 2020, scientists found
the giant Siphonophore Apolemia,
an organism made up of millions
of interconnected clones,
its thin twisting body reminiscent
of a long piece of string.
And the ocean floor is far from being
the flat and featureless seabed
you might imagine.
If you were to drain the ocean,
a landscape would emerge just
as spectacular as anything on land -
boasting some of the highest peaks,
deepest canyons and longest
river channels on the planet.
There are even waterfalls
under the sea -
the largest being
the Denmark Strait cataract.
Here, the cold waters
of the Greenland Sea
meet the warmer waters
of the Irminger.
As the cooler water is forced down,
it creates a giant three and a half
thousand metre drop,
undetectable to anyone who might
be bobbing about on the surface.
And that’s nothing compared
to the chilling 11,000 metre drop
to the bottom of the Mariana Trench -
the deepest place on Earth.
It was here that, in 2020, scientists
made an alarming discovery.
At a depth of around 7,000 metres,
in one of the most remote
and inaccessible crevices on Earth,
they came across
a new species of crustacean.
And it had plastic in its stomach.
They called it Eurythenes plasticus -
a living reminder that,
even though we’ve barely begun
to explore the ocean,
our impact on it is already
being keenly felt.
In fact, by 2050,
it’s estimated there could be more
plastic in the sea than fish.
But it’s not just plastic
that’s a problem.
There are also “dead zones”,
areas with insufficient oxygen
to support marine life.
These are becoming more common
thanks to pollution.
The sad truth is,
when it comes to the ocean,
the reach of human activity
goes far beyond the reach
of our knowledge.
It’s easy to feel detached
from the ocean -
particularly if you live inland.
And this might explain why
we’ve treated it as a dumping ground.
But the more we explore,
the more we find it has to offer.
For example, the gene pool
of deep ocean life,
such as sponges and microorganisms,
could hold the key to solving
the urgent problem
of antibiotic resistance.
More importantly, the ocean is key
to almost all life on the planet.
Half the oxygen we breathe
comes from marine photosynthesizers
such as phytoplankton
and seaweed.
The ocean also regulates our climate,
mediating temperature by distributing
solar heat around the planet.
We may not feel it, but every
one of us is affected every day
by the role the ocean plays in our
finely-balanced Earth system.
And yet, the efforts
we’ve made so far
to protect and preserve
this vital life source
are, well, a drop in the ocean.
There’s still so much
we don’t know -
so many breathtaking canyons unseen,
so many creatures undiscovered -
but new technology is revealing more
about our ocean than ever before.
Perhaps if we knew more
of the ocean’s secrets
we might look after it better.